alors joe vous avez une fille qui
s'appelle bonnut oui hein
et elle doit souvent vous posez des
questions sur le monde sur la vie sur
les gens sur les idées ouais c'est vrai
ça va vous falloir une interview
expliqué à massy en bouche par le mouche
pendant le signal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien alors imaginez donc je suis
votre fille et je vous pose des
questions pas passé il faut bien petit
revient sur travail à faire ah bon je
pense pas que ce soit très compliqué
pour vous fera pas c'est quoi un bon
boulot c'est un petit gâteau d'un petit
gâteau qui s'est vendu dans les années
80 et il y avait un noir de 6,1 j'ai
grandi avec ça c'était une catastrophe
et aussi le tête de [ __ ] encore en
pâtisserie qui se vend très bien alors
c'est étrange que ce soit
systématiquement sur une communauté en
particulier que ce type de chose arrive
et c'est vrai c'est regarder ils
réfléchissent n'y a pas d'autres
bâtisses antilles
il n'y a pas de tête de chinois ou c'est
vrai oui un [ __ ] en chemise aussi papa
toujours votre fille à un boni pourquoi
tu t'es pas présenté pour être maire de
dreux parce que comme dans beaucoup de
villes de france mon enfant tu sais
la droite s'est allié au front national
pour faire liste commune dès le premier
tour il faut se retirer
faut se battre contre ces gens là a donc
je suis cette fois-ci retirer et
apporter mon soutien la liste de jean
pierre lesage en très bon bon contre la
folie environ c'était un lg pas bien me
faire un bisou aussi serré à la fin a
répondu pas paris dis moi papa c'est
vrai que tu vas être président de la
république
oui je serai le prochain président ma
fille je serai aussi le dernier
parce que c'est moi qui vais
démissionner cette fonction sera plus de
président après il ya plus besoin de
président que ce calibre il ya plus de
me faire plus de frontières déjà 1,1
président de quoi bof bof bof chacun des
présidents de chez soi chez sa carcasse
est d'accord avec ça georges marc est ce
qu'on devrait tous avoir une carte de
citoyen du monde et qu'il ait plus de
frontières plus de pays puis de
président jean ont fait l'europe serait
pas mal 1 2 ont fait leur oeuvre
moi c'est pour ça que président de la
france bon ça c'est pas complètement
faux mais dit pas que des conneries non
dit papa pour en voir bout la voit pas
papa tu avais dit qu avec jospin y
aurait plus de sans papiers et à la télé
on en voit encore c'est mieux et c'est
pas gagné sa mère est pourquoi toi papa
on ne voit plus trop à la télé si rien
n'est fait j'y vais et puis parce que tu
sais je fais j'ai fait des films là j'ai
joué au théâtre est venu me voir
d'ailleurs elle bien aimé l'esprit que
tu es monté sur scène un at il va faire
combien tu veux faire premier à faire
attention on fait attention pourquoi pas
parce que je veux faire comme semi bugzy
peux pas je vais être acteur et pas
pourquoi il n'y a pas beaucoup de noirs
à la td est belle ma fille tu sais ça
s'est fait doucement 1
il y avait un code noir et une justice
qui déterminait club noir n'était pas
égale à l'homme blanc même un pape qui a
dit que l'homme noir n'avaient pas de
conscience tu sais ça remonte à l'ong
allemande a dit ça we will dernier n'a
pas dit ça évidemment mais
mais il est issu d'une vieille tradition
et puis c'est un c'est un monde qui a
considéré que le bois renée n'était pas
un homme et un sous-homme et encore
quand on va chercher du boulot quand on
va aux loges et quand tu iras j'espère
que ça sera à ranger d'ici là mais tu
aura plus de problèmes que les autres
il va y avoir plus de noirs à la télé
oui je pense qu'il y en a déjà un peu
plus donc ça va mieux
oui bien sûr l'espoir il est devant
toute façon la merdasse c'est derrière
pas pourquoi le président de la
république jacques chirac
il va pas voir le juge qui l'a convoqué
parce que tu sais on enfants en ce
moment il ya une chose très importante
qui est en train de se passer derrière
ça à tcc qui détient les bonnes valeurs
et la morale la justice ou les élus
craintes et plus tu essaies on est dans
un système en même temps cette justice
est la même qui emprisonne des sans
papiers qui tolère le commerce des
bombes et des armes et de l'autre côté
tu as un homme qui qui lui représentant
commerce justement et puis en même temps
ça ne m'étonnerait qu'elle parle de
jacques chirac moscou lui en a jamais
parlé
papa c'est quoi les verts pourquoi ils
sont pas tous vers les verts allons peut
être noir et vert regard stéphane
jacquin et stéphane pocrain est belle
est versé et c'est une force politique
qui commence à grandir dans ce pays et
puis il faudra bien toute façon que tu
vois que ça se renouvelle et puis là il
ya un nouveau parti qui est plus proche
plus proche des autres plus proche de
l'environnement regarde en afrique quand
tu vas chez grand père chez papy masse
et des gens qui vivent pas pareil avec
leur environnement sont des verts aussi
sont des écolos sont les gens qui au
quotidien vivre dans une autre relation
qui sont pas dans une hystérie de la
productivité comme certains bon il ya
des avantages et des inconvénients
tu as vu quand tu vas chez papy il
faudrait pas d'eau chaude c'est bien mon
papier j'aime bien les suppôts pee wee
et papa c'est vrai qu'il faut plus
manger de danone
ah oui ça c'est vrai ah c'est vrai parce
qu'à l'école on m'a dit on mange plus de
danone chez nous on mange plus ne valent
rien pourquoi parce qu'il faut partir et
c'est mauvais ça donne la chair
mais papa j'ai entendu évitons ancien
copain qui a dit à la radio que tu
pensais qu'au fric
bah oui parce qu'il fallait bien qu'il
trouve quelque chose mais tu sais bombe
à lui il a vendu beaucoup de cassettes a
eu beaucoup plus d'impôts peut pas donc
ça m'énerve un petit peu près mais bon
c'est son copain pas d'accord c'est
quand même son copain balawi un gros
plan reste encore pas bien il vaut mieux
aimer jésus ou coluche sont les mêmes ce
sont deux grands humoristes de
l'histoire et papa comment roule un
joint
tiens va chercher la boîte là bas et
papa pourquoi on meurt c'est très
important
c'est très important ça arrive à un
moment où tu prévois pas et c'est mieux
comme ça et est pas si tu leur pas tu
vis par toi c'est la mort la mort ça
n'existe pas si on vient obligé de
mourir en fait c'est une mauvaise
question je sais pas qui tu as posé
cette question ça allait passer à
l'école c'est la petite lapide semoun
petit cerveau c'est la petite semoun qui
m'a dit de mandji à ton père j'ai
téléphoné à son père son ballet lever
ces gens c'est parce que tu vas mourir
que tu rigole moins qu'avant
non tu sais je rigole toujours autant tu
m'as vu comme bon à la maison c'est vrai
que tu as fait des bêtises aussi c'est
normal que je rigole poteau c'est vrai
ma puce mais enfin
enfin non non tu sais papa il a toujours
rigoler on a tous pris ta énervez pas
passer le jour où tu m'as trouve en
train de lire minutes tu te souviens oui
quand on ferait rentrer dans la police
alors vanessa paradis vous êtes devenue
une mère très très attentif vous êtes
ordonné maintenant avant vous vous
faites les valises quand vous partez en
qu'on vous partez en vacances c'était
une réponse sérieuse donc confère une
interview très sérieuses et c'est
l'interview expliqué à ma fille en la
bouche pendant le dégagement raté
votre fille vous demande maintenant
pourquoi on meurt encore mr ce qu'est
mon histoire et un début un milieu et
une fin
et puis il faut bien que ça s'arrête
semble au bout d'un moment on devient
complètement à massy à la cuillère mais
après il ya autre chose surtout j'ai dit
ah vous dirais ça sert à quoi de
travailler puisqu'il suffit d'aller à la
machine pour prendre de l'argent
baa à occuper ses journées et a mangé
mon père est dit c'est le taxi de la
liberté l'argent j'aime bien cet ex
principal taxi c'est récurrent maman
c'est quoi ce que vous mettez dans vos
cigarettes avec papa
amélie et non j'ai eu explique pour
l'instant sans moi c'est du tabac donc
ça va ya pas de problème pas trop bien
non mais de toute façon j'ai lui
expliquerai je prends moi je préfère
citer puisse passer les frontières
tranquille
vite il aussi aux états unis moi
pourquoi papa il a fait un baiser sur la
bouche à la baby sitter
bagis tirait mais parce que parce qu'il
aime bien qui voulait lui dire bonjour
puis après 50 balles de leur en faut
quand même par un bisou quoi maman
pourquoi on t'entend mois la radio en ce
moment parce que parce que les gens les
aiment pas trop méchants sont en ce
moment et dit maman qu'est la question
qui n'a pas de réponse c'est chiant les
gosses c'est pourquoi pourquoi je t'aime
pas de réponse c'est comme ça que on ne
bouge pas pendant que ting
moi
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire quoi ami aime les sucettes
à l'anis ça veut rien dire mais si cette
année voit la grand-mère de son à la
télé il à dinah faust veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que c'est une nymphe a
investi 9 au masculin comme hambourg et
grand-mère info adam vous servir une
information une grand mère oui
admin chérie ça veut dire quoi d'amo à
traiter d'abord saluer un chanteur belge
est d'accord les grands-mères comment
rouler un joint
alors ça écoute je ne sais pas on va
dire que j'ai vu je ne sais pas du tout
est clair oui papa il a fait un bisou
sur la bouche à la baby sitter
il a fait ça
je m'étais c'est un truc terrible à pau
grand mère oui ma soeur elle a dit
[ __ ] ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que c'est quelqu'un qui
vous prend par derrière grand meilleur
pourquoi chirac m'a dit oui le président
de la république il paraît qu'il est
convoqué chez le juge il veut pas y
aller pourquoi
et puis et puis johnny hallyday il a une
mercedes et puis toi tu n'as pas grand
mère pourquoi parce que on a sept
français grand mère oui papa il est
était sur le lit il est monté sur le
baby sitter
et puis ça lui a fait mal à la publicité
pas de crier pourquoi elle criait grand
mère parce qu'ils se rendent pas compte
qu'il est lourd
j'aimerais bien
merde oui pourquoi dieu là il n'y a pas
de femmes non parce qu'il aime pas les
hommes ont la bouche pendant le tig
[Applaudissements]
il ya beaucoup de belles fiche ce soir
c'est la petite fille qui parle à
travers moi à bombay maman maman
pourquoi personne
m ben laden elle est très fasciné par sa
barbe ça par contre ça l'est pas mais
c'est vrai qu'il a un sourire à seydou
mairie les enfants se rendent pas compte
peut-être qu'ils le trouvent sympathique
oui sauf que ma fille
pas vraiment parce qu'en plus
son papa est américain donc donc voilà
ça change je sais pas qui c'est sans
papa moi je lis ici alors toujours votre
petite fille maman maman pourquoi johnny
il a une mercedes et toi tu n'as pas
parce que je n'ai beaucoup moins j'ai
beaucoup moins d'argent que johnny est
que je n'ai pas le goût
j'ai pas un goût prononcé pour les
voitures et que j'ai un renault espace
et menaçant d une franchement c'est un
peu anti sexy renault espace pour une
fille comme bouquet très jolie existe
une très jolie fille très jolie femme
dans une renault espace ça vous met pas
en valeur faut acheter une capacité de
marque mais il ya plein de voitures qui
vous irait mieux mais j'ai pas besoin de
ça pour mettre en valeur
mais moi bien alors maman maman de deux
petites filles
comment on fait les bébés eh ben on met
la petite graine j'aime beaucoup le
jardinage et maman ça veut dire quoi
annie aime les sucettes à l'anis
j'ai passé les gosses
moi je répondrai tout simplement que
c'est très très bon lait ce satané voilà
tu vas encore une personne géniale voilà
encore une question de la petite jeanne
dit maman c'est quoi la question qui n'a
pas de réponse peut-être celle de
thierry ardisson au pluriel
non non si votre petite fille qui parle
par ma bouche comme dans l'exorciste dit
maman il est où papa est un papa il n'a
pas voulu de toi dis maman c'est qu'ils
jean-edouard je te montre avec a7 tu
comprendras dit maman tu m'aimes bien
stv oui j'aime beaucoup et baffie tulle
aime bien jusque là ça va on verra plus
tard et hardy sont très sains allumeuse
dis maman comment on fait les bébés
spectre un peu plus tard quand on a
grandi
ah bon tu m'expliqueras loana dis maman
pourquoi le monsieur qui vient des fois
la maison il tombera sur la bouche
ah parce que parce qu'il aime beaucoup
pourquoi on ne voit plus tout le temps à
la télé parce que je préfère m'occuper
de toi m'a dit maman
le monsieur qui embrasse tout le temps
sur la bouche il a fait la même chose à
la baby sitter mais n'a pu revenir le
monsieur s'est mise il dit maman on va
rester toujours ensemble maintenant
josé est ce que vous avez le temps de
voir vos enfants avec tout ça elles sont
grandes
il y en a une qui a 29 ans et l'autre 27
ans ouais donc je les ai plus au
téléphone que que devant moi oui alors
comme vous les voyez pas très souvent
elles m'ont chargé de vous poser
quelques questions interview expliqué à
ma fille
[Musique]
dis papa paysans c'est gagner du blé pas
trop ouais pourquoi tu es toujours à la
télé jamais à la ferme papa ben comme ça
au moins je peux vous voir un faux c'est
vous qui me voyez thème bien faire la
vedette papa non c'est jamais été ma
tasse de thé
pourquoi j'ai pas le droit d'aller au
mcdo avec mes copains parce qu'elles
devront décider elle même que je
trouvais pas ça bon voir ce que va papa
la péter papa la cervelle d'agneau tu
crois que ces milliards le big mac
incontestablement avec des caprins tu as
peur de repartir en prison
c'est quelque chose auquel je pense je
suis prêt à l'assumer mais sait jamais
avec plaisir qu'on va en prison rhin
j'ai essayé de s'évader papa non mais
par contre comme chaque personne qui
était en prison tu fais toujours un plan
sur la comète pour t'évader qui est tout
ce que tu te dire là bas y paraît et
pourquoi moi je vois tu obéis on peut
pas si toi tu obéis à personne a joué
jamais demandé de mobilire toujours un
mes films ont souvent résister
heureusement quand ya des caméras
étaient encore plus courageux ou non non
ça change rien
tu aimerais que ce soit paysanne mois
par 2,5 en valeur
c'est vraiment alors c'est leur choix
elles ont le temps de choisir ils
peuvent toujours le faire dans son temps
papa tu crois qu'ils auront encore des
paysans j'espère parce que sinon ça va
être vraiment la fin de la planète
pourquoi tu voulais pas qu'ils aient la
ferme parce que je pense que c'était
vraiment qu'on annonce était bien la
regarder on est à fond dedans ne t'a pas
vu arrêter on n'est pas content non je
pense que c'était grotesque dans ça
n'avait pas ça n'avait aucun sens
allez vite que les gens fassent un show
de ce type là mais ce qui était pas
sympa pour les téléspectateurs ceux qui
voyaient pas le derrière de la faire on
n'a pas vu la belle pis si on n'a pas vu
tout ça donc c'est vrai que c'était
vraiment du cinéma quoi cette embêter
qu'on voit qu'on peut faire ton boulot
avec des talents au papa c'est à dire
que peut-être que pour marcher dans le
fumier c'est mieux parce qu'au moins on
s'accroche pas ouais t'as déjà pris de
la drogue papa j'ai pu mais oui bien sûr
pourquoi tu cultiverait pas de la drogue
en disant que c'est la désobéissance
civile va pas je n'écoute chez moi ça
pousse pas très bien et elles le savent
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'eau donc je
crois pas qu'on aurait des très beaux
pieds c'est obligé la moustache et la
peep quand on est paysan papa moi je
crois pas parce qu'on a pas mal d'un
verbe aussi un moment elle dit que tu
adores les pipes c'est vrai hein j'adore
ça oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu